carlos bustamante et Canada thank you
for that this is like it's it's a fun
episode to watch it's a fun show to
watch you get into a lot of really
interesting topics about love but I mean
in your episode it's there's a joy of so
much joy in it you guys are having so
much fun together doing it was it no no
you're right there's no so much joy and
it was it was a pleasure and so much fun
to work with Andrew and Olivia and the
set was really just a warm loving place
to kind of tell this story so yeah yeah
on your Instagram you said that you were
sick while you were sick so sick like
second day in and then for the rest of
the week I was just
I'm almost reading weirdest that we were
filming in a hospital yes I came in I
thought him I'm good and the medic took
my pressure she was like you're about to
faint I have to admit you to the
hospital yes so they were shooting on
one floor and I was
[Laughter]
you've been getting so much attention
for a hot priest monthly bag lately how
are you taking that um yeah it's it's
mind-blowing really yeah it's definitely
something new incredible it's incredible
people you know people don't come up and
say it's the Internet it's just ordinary
I think you know things sister you gotta
get on it yelling it at you when you're
no you know people just you know people
will say any number of things on the
internet like streaming videos French
SME videos that's my priest I'm like oh
my gosh this we're talking about modern
love what have you guys learned in your
life anything about love an important
lesson either about giving love or
receiving love but it takes work the
love is not an easy thing that just
happens it's like you have to make a
choice when you were loving somebody and
that relationship takes work to maintain
that love and to allow it to evolve and
to grow and it's not gonna look like
what it looked like when you guys first
met yeah I has to evolve it needs space
to breathe that's the most important
thing yeah the conflict and you know
arguing you know leads to a deeper love
you know everything running smoothly and
just keeping us through as maintaining a
status quo isn't actually kind of deep
in your love sometimes actually having
an argument or deeper discussion leads
to you go oh I didn't know that now I
know that about you and then you get
deeper and deeper and deeper yeah that's
real genuine and it teaches you about
yourself too like loving somebody forces
you to kind of put the mirror at
yourself as well right on thank you
gents awesome
you